[Music]
so cool there are 110 pepperoni slices
on this pizza Oh workout huh
welcome back to making a big the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I've invited in
Hannah Williams she's one of our
earliest tasty producers and makes
really fun and awesome videos with her
family on mom in progress let's go meet
her and see what she wants to eat today
was it good how are you good for the
people that don't know you what do you
do we better know me I'm just kidding I
do a show on BuzzFeed called mom in
progress it stars my family it's like a
family vlogging show a lot of it is
giving the kids a little bit of control
and just seeing what happens like I let
the kids in you'll plan our week which I
feel like in hindsight I should not have
given them seven full days it was just
junk but I was very proud that we
completed it and I stuck to my word it
sounds like you guys do a lot of stuff
around food I'd love to make a giant
food for you today is there anything
that you have in mind that you'd like me
to make it from you how would you feel
about doing something for the kids
oh yeah that's awesome yeah I know for a
fact that if they were to be presented
with a giant pizza their hats would
probably explode okay
so I've made a giant pizza episode it
wasn't a whole pizza it was a three-foot
slice and to be honest like I don't
think it was as big as I could have like
I was like kind of proud of it but I
think that there are ways that we can
make the pizza a lot bigger than the
video that I've made so bigger than
three feet I don't know how you're gonna
pin it in an oven we might have to go
find another oven if you maybe want to
ask Wyatt and Jackson what their
favorite toppings are I want to
customize it so they get like the pizza
of their dreams all right let's do it
for the kids so we are at this place
called big Mama's in Papa's pizzeria
they make this giant 54 inch pizza
they've got this huge oven and I think
they're a great fit to make this giant
piece of for a white in Jackson I spoke
with the owner his name's Tito super
cool and he agreed to let me come in try
and make the giant pizza with him I'm
very
to make this so let's go check it out
[Music]
how's it going tico good good thank you
for the apron and the shirt it looks
really cool tell me about the pizza
we're gonna make today so what we got
here is the giant Sicilian is 54 by 54
inches weighs about 50 pounds so you got
40 pounds of dough about 5 pounds of
cheese 5 pounds of sauce it's actually
the Guinness Book of Records for the
largest deliverable yourself
really Wow what is this this is the
screen that the pizza is gonna go on I
was like that the pan yeah exactly at
home my pan is like this isn't this way
what's the first thing that we got the
first thing we got to make the dough
okay so let's go over here the dough
going so I see a very large mixer what
do we do how do we make this one out so
we got to get the flour okay so open
this bag up I see that this has your
guyses pizzeria on it yeah custom blend
this is custom okay it's a secret flower
button so we're gonna pour this in okay
you'll have to tell me at least some of
the greens in here
no I mean there's your typical yeast
flour and sugar and a few others Oh
yeah something special I like that oh
this is heavy
yeah dump that in there Wow delicate
perfect whoa now we got to get the
bucket of ice and water ice some water
okay why do you use ice to keep it fresh
you gotta make sure it's the right
amount okay right to the line second
amount okay and then we're gonna add
some water to it this is probably
another one 25 30 pounds of water yeah
ice the work out to make this pizza is
not easy I really get into you want to
dump it in there I gotta do some work I
don't want alright wow that's just
expected now wow that's crazy
darkness press Start yeah thank you this
will take about 25 to 30 minutes okay
yeah cuz the ice - right yeah that's
really cool don't work Tico alright now
we got the dough it's ready to go okay
this is where we open the pizza so you
want to get some flour on it so there's
a stick some on the table so it doesn't
get stuck oh okay so I can try it or
it's yeah oh sorry
don't worry oh god I'm sorry alright so
now we're gonna bring the dough
alright cool how many pounds of dough is
that this is 40 pounds 40 pounds of
dough Wow ready yeah
nice and what do you mean by opening the
dough so we're gonna have to slowly
start pushing it to get it closer to the
size of the pizza so you want to just
push like that kind of like massaging it
are you good at giving massages no but I
love receiving are you trying to go from
inside out where do you start this yeah
you wanna yeah nope going great
alright so what we're gonna do get our
hands down under yeah like this pretty
much okay we'll hold it like this okay
we'll take it over onto that's right so
what you can do if you get it to one
edge okay want to wrap it wrap it around
yeah I wanna finish bed sheet yeah yeah
okay
stretch it this way oh yeah from the
sides or sides
yeah stretch it more like that it's
perfect yeah
[Music]
that's pretty stretched out right yeah
looking good Rudy I was okay here yeah
perfect oh wow perfect
he said perfect thank you what is the
next step next thing we got a poke holes
in it whoa what does that mean this is
like a torture device okay what is the
process like so you just got a roll up
and down I try it looks like graham
crackers perfect perfect all right now
we got the pizza sauce okay Oh
interesting I would usually think that a
pizza this big would need a lot but I
guess you found the right balance of
sauce that across okay so what we're
gonna go you can grab this we're gonna
spread it throughout the dough and then
we'll just spread it off and the gloves
on okay cool you want to put some I can
try start with the edges okay and we'll
work our way in oh boy Hey oh is that
okay yeah there's no right or wrong you
just want to get it around there's no
wrong
I like Willis guy
[Music]
we got our gloves what I want to do is
just spread it out nicely there nice and
evenly kind of like this axe right just
how to leave a little crust there okay
got it
this is the fun part of the fun part
right your hands all in there kind of
feels like when you know finger paint
I said yeah exactly how did you guys
develop this pizza it started with the
Big Mama pizza which is a 28-inch uh-huh
and then we went okay we gotta do
something more unique then we noticed
that the size of the oven is about 55
inches so we're I can't let's see how
far we can push this were you were just
born one night you're like oh the
biggest he's like avenge it's something
unique something that kids love it's
more easier when you're catering instead
of getting like 10 15 different pizzas
you just got one huge one this looks
perfect yeah why don't we go through
most of everything covered
all right where X is the cheese it's a
lot of cheese yeah it's a mixture of
mozzarella cheese and provolone cheese
Parmesan cheese Wow yes we're gonna do
the same thing with the pizza sauce
we're gonna grab it spread it out
throughout like this just so we won't go
all around the edges oh boy here we go
perfect I'm all shaky don't worry about
it cuz I have to be perfect we're gonna
spread it out anyway we'll just grab
your hands okay yeah we'll grab in just
sprinkle it huh
and how much cheese is this this is five
pounds five pounds of cheese okay the
same thing we're kind of spreading it
out making it even that good yeah how
much do you guys get this requested to
be made we do about seven a month I
would say it's a lot of work yeah we
also have a challenge for this so it's
eight people we have two hours to finish
it the whole thing the whole thing and
you get a thousand dollars how many
people have finished it we've had a few
people do it actually in December the
record was for people in 34 minutes I
believe the job cavemen were these
giants perfect that looks great this
looks good yep nice all right so what
toppings are you doing so the kids
there's this end over little video
what's your favorite food Jackson my his
pizza
what's yours Wyatt cheese pizza Wyatt
enough with no I saw that so I was maybe
thinking because this is a square would
it be possible to almost like have four
quadrants yeah Oh we'll do a quarter
cheese quarter pepper olives that's
great I'm perfect all right so we got
the ingredients we got the pepperoni
olives and the sliced ham yeah
which speaking of which sliced hands I
remember when I first started working
the restaurant I didn't know how to cut
that one okay
so I'll cut like really slow so I'll be
just you know taking my time making sure
everything was okay and then my boss
would
by covering just parking so he thought I
was a professional cutter that didn't
work
of course yeah he was like this oh sorry
God yeah maybe let star with the
pepperoni King is there like a strategy
for how to arrange it at least every
slice to have two slices I like there
only for sure and each one is about
maybe a quarter inch apart
exactly okay I've seen a lot of pizzas
were like it starts out far and then
toppings become close because the cheese
okay that is actually from a lot of
cheese you put too much cheese it starts
melting so it moves oh so not only are
you thinking about how much sauce you
put how much you put affects the way the
top exact that's that's big brain level
that's 3,000 IQ how many calories do you
think this entire piece is come over a
thousand for sure yeah I think the
cheese alone might be over a thousand so
I think I'm a little slow knows don't
worry if you don't yeah you look perfect
started olives that'd be great yeah I
think by the time you finish - he'll be
done for this layer I'm just gonna make
a ring somewhere all those oh yeah make
it I like I like the way this guy talks
oh he beat me I can't even finish this
before he's there or five six seven
eight nine
there are 110 have her Oni slices on
this pizza naturally at its horror and
that's just 1/4 the whole thing would
have had 440 pepperoni slices what is
the next step okay talk to me about how
do you bake a 50 pound a 54 inch slice
pizza how is that different than in just
a normal slice well it takes much longer
and instead of just being able to turn
it around in the oven we're gonna have
to take it completely out turn around
and put it back in oh my god we won't
grab this side I grab this side let's do
so oh wow this is amazing
there you go oh so it like kind of hangs
about a hang up the oven timely isn't
big enough we could take it out cool
yeah look at that it's like a whole
field it um pizza like farm of ham here
you got a garlic olives we got the city
of pepperoni back there this is really
good okay so this cooks for how long oh
we're giving it about 15 minutes okay
we'll turn it around all right well I'll
get to see you guys in 30 minutes okay
so now we're gonna take it out try to
cook the other quarter of it you got it
Oh mate let it on this table here is so
heavy this way and we'll put this side
in ha ha
yeah yeah let's go let's go whoa oh man
this is a workout yeah I don't know how
you do it oh my god
now we're gonna do about another 15 15
15 minutes huh we'll turn into another
cool and check it yeah all right cool
all right turn number two yeah looks
amazing
yeah I understand what you have to cook
it a bit at a time yeah we'll get this
side in Superman Wow perfect whoa
Oh workout huh don't work so I put some
oil on the crust uh-huh to keep it yeah
Bernie something this large you never
know right let's go yeah here we go
we're pros now yeah cool 15 minutes
we'll be back here so we're gonna have
to take it out and then slide it off
directly okay so this is like the
toughest part right this is yeah all
right I won't tell you I got it got this
last one is slowly out again yeah you
got it yeah so we're gonna just tilt it
a little bit until we get the edge some
room we can grab off from the
oh just pull this out
whoa nice good job
nice work that was that was crazy let's
go inside
Wow so we delivered this on top of our
smart card got a custom layup like when
you're going on a ski trip and you like
Robbie the back yeah you only do that
out let's do it all right
got it let's go feel like I'm in a mario
party game and up in shoulder press
all right nice okay well no jump today
yeah no don't eat it goes into the car
driving this back to the BuzzFeed
headquarters not at all all right cool I
will meet you there
sounds good right all right you're
welcome
[Music]
all righty
oh it's nice we're back at BuzzFeed
Thank You Tico for driving it all the
way over I'm very excited to have the
kids try it out they don't feel that fun
thank you for letting in their kitchen
thank you um but yeah I'm very excited
no peeking
I okay cover your eyes okay on the count
of three guys I want you guys to open
eyes ready one two three
take a look you guys want to see the
inside yeah all right I'll take the lid
off
[Music]
this is my best day ever
yeah you guys guess how many pounds this
entire pizzas 100 millions very close
how many people do you think it would
take to finish it yes gonna finish this
entire piece guys hey Wyatt which slice
do you want yeah
oh you're gonna make me reach all the
way over there okay do you see why
anything of course
so of course you can have changed music
there you go mr. Jackson thank you
holding up next to your face let me see
that is longer than your face it's the
best beauty you've ever had this is
better than New York
[Music]
[Music]
amazing you've got some tomato sauce
turn yellow though thank you for coming
keep up the good work in school okay
listen to your mom I love you guys so
much I know how much you love peace well
this is it that's that that is it okay
sorry I'll do that [ __ ] well this is it
that was the season finale for a season
two of tasties making a big I hope you
guys had as much fun as me thank you for
all the support so far your ideas are
always appreciated so keep sending them
keep them coming we always aren't making
great and awesome things for awesome
people until next time
[Music]